because it wasn't
the first thing that came out their
mouth was i can't believe 19 kids die
they go well this is what happens when
you're not protected at all times you
better not take my guns yeah that took
precedence before having a conversation
about 19 children losing their lives
exactly which bothers me yeah it doesn't
even piss me off it makes me sad it
makes me sad and it infuriates me yeah
because the fact is
where does that mindset stem from
entitlement in five four three two one
what's up everybody welcome to another
episode of the genius brain podcast i am
back from south korea the homeland the
motherland
the place where i was born but not happy
to be back no america's a little uh you
know a little unstable listen if you
guys haven't ever or just you've never
traveled to i don't know asia
it's weird listen i love america yeah i
appreciate everything that america has
done for me you know in terms of
opportunities that has given my family
and also their stuff it's all great this
[ __ ] sucks here listen
it's crazy how technologically advanced
south korea is
in terms of how efficient it is yeah
specifically public transportation
the public transportation is pretty
amazing in terms of like if you want to
get a taxi grab a taxi if not a taxi
that you can get go to use a subway
right and the subway is faster than the
taxi and even the buses are faster than
the taxi because the buses have a
separate lane in which they can travel
and there's nobody else allowed to be in
that lane besides buses there's almost
no need for a car unless you want to go
to the airport but even then you can go
to the airport
on the train yeah so having a car is
almost useless yeah i mean but to be
fair it's a lot more condensed because
right
i heard there's this whole i'm not sure
if it's a conspiracy or if it's fact but
the reason why
you know america has terrible public
transportation stem is specifically
because of the gas industry makes sense
like the gas industry i heard like in la
too or i was reading and once again this
is something i read in passing at night
you know when i was going down the
rabbit hole yeah but the the train
system was supposed to be developed in a
very efficient way but somehow the car
companies and gas companies got in the
way in terms of like legislation yeah to
[ __ ] it all up and that's why we have
the worst public transportation system
here yeah which it doesn't make sense
because if we're supposed to the most
advanced nation something as simple as
good public transportation should be
readily available for sure for sure
that's something that um i feel like
major metropolitan cities in america are
pretty much lack well i guess aside from
new york right new york but even new
york it's not it's not good but it's not
like the worst let's say new york versus
la la's public transportation is garbage
it's non-existent pretty much it's like
when i go into a train in korea i feel
as clean as i felt when i walked in
when you walk into a train in new york
yeah you you you've caught 17 versions
of kobe yeah it is disgusting and you
might you might see some you know a
crazy dude masturbating you know with
his pants off
a free show baby let's go
it's just it's kind of crazy man and you
know when i was in korea we're going to
talk about this on the podcast because
obviously you know i think it should be
talked about and we've we've definitely
touched on this subject before but when
i was in south korea i you know when i'm
traveling i'm traveling i'm doing my
thing and obviously i was uploading
content over there because i was just
excited to show people the stuff that i
i got to eat and see yeah which by the
way you did a good job with it on the
reels so you know what the funny thing
was i actually brought my camera with me
yeah i used it one day and i left it
everything was on the it was on the
phone it's too heavy i know it's
inconvenient man also too in korea and
also japan people prefer their privacy
you can't just whip out a phone and
start recording people right and you
would have to ask them and even then
when you did ask they would feel
uncomfortable but if it's a phone it's a
little different like there's no way i
would have been able to bring my dslr on
the subway and film everybody exactly
they would have been like excuse me like
don't do that yeah you know that's how
it was in japan too it was kind of hard
so i kind of remembered that and i
decided to just use my phone and i got a
lot of footage in the restaurant and
other places that i wouldn't have been
able to get with a camera yeah but
honestly too these days like
you don't really need the extra camera
if you're trying to let your content
live on instagram you don't need a dslr
right right yeah you don't and nobody
gives a [ __ ] yeah
right you just have to just add color to
it use like vsco and then be able to
make it look a certain way i like the
vintage like super 1990s like vhs look
right so i was you know emulating like
fuji film type of stuff which yeah i
thought it looked great yeah
so you don't really need that but i was
in korea and then apparently like the
whole world was exploding while i was
there right because i wasn't looking at
the news and when i came back i found
out that there's well the the the
shooting that happened was when i was
here and it was literally after i got
out of the dudes behind the foods
podcast with tim and we were getting a
burger and then on the screen tim was
like yo look
and at the time it said 12 kids were
dead
right that number is now 19 yeah and
then two staff members i believe or two
teachers or whoever it was yeah which is
[ __ ] nuts but even before we even
touched that there was two previous
shootings in the two weeks that i was in
korea well
not to mention bro that with just the
school shootings this is the 27th one
this year this [ __ ] [ __ ] in 2022
that's the 20 at least the 27th shooting
you know what i mean so
every time we see [ __ ] like this happen
and we touched up on this in december
when we were talking about it right yeah
yeah
it's like oh well
here's another [ __ ] mass shooting
yeah whether it was at the school at the
[ __ ] supermarket at a church like
it's another [ __ ] day in america
and it's like at what point do we say it
is like enough is enough
like
it's not it's bad enough as it is that
people are dying but when it's [ __ ]
children innocent children who are at
school
and and our thing is well we're not
gonna [ __ ] do anything with gun
reform laws what we're gonna do is we're
gonna teach the kids how to hide how
what's due in a shooter situation an
active shooter situation how to run away
and it's like well good luck now you're
prepared now you're equipped with the
necessary tools yeah i mean
if you guys don't know so there was a
school out in texas i don't know which
city uvalde uvalde texas yeah uh there
was uh i think he was hispanic right
yeah he was hispanic male um he actually
had like a bulletproof vest on
uh
automatic or semi-automatic rifle and i
don't understand what the motivation was
behind it to why he did it and i don't
think nobody will know because they had
to gun him down yeah but essentially
when we were watching it on the news
there was 12 kids that were reported
dead and that number jumped by seven it
was 19 kids were murdered you know this
[ __ ] killed his own grandma too
oh really yeah
that same day yeah
yeah also he was just alphabetical he
was he was on some [ __ ] you know and you
know what when we talk about these
shootings we don't ever [ __ ] mention
the names of these shooters because
these [ __ ] don't deserve that
kind of attention and recognition ever
yeah they'll be [ __ ] nameless like
the pieces of [ __ ] that they are
and this guy
unfortunately i believe he took his own
life too so he he's not going to face
any repercussion or jail time or
whatever i thought the cops shot him now
or maybe it was the cop i don't i don't
know all i know is he's dead that's the
weird thing too and i don't know if this
is you know sadistic of me or because i
hate this human being so much yeah i
don't want them to die i i think that
they should live [ __ ] rot in jail for
the rest of their life jail be tortured
or something because it sucks that this
person gets to do what they do because
they don't already don't care about
their life yeah well they don't care
about the life then they should have it
not because it's something that they
that they deserve to live but they need
to live with their consequences and
you know what
i'll tell you this
the human mind is fragile you could
torture the [ __ ] out of somebody oh for
sure so i i when i found out that he was
shot down or gunned down and he died i
was pissed i'm like no he needs to live
yeah he needs to live because he needs
to
suffer through every [ __ ] thing
possible in order for retribution to
take place it's too it's too small of a
price to pay for what they've done yeah
you know it's too easy it's too [ __ ]
easy for them to just lose their life
after committing a heinous crime like
that yeah and it's just like
you know steve steve kerr gave a really
passionate speech about it yesterday in
the press conference leading up to you
know the western conference finals and
you know people don't realize the reason
why steve kerr is so passionate about
the you know gun violence is that his
father was a victim of gun violence his
father was assassinated wow yeah he got
shot by two guys i think he was at the
university of beirut um and then it was
kind of like an attack against america
of sorts they were targeting americans i
guess and his father was i think a
professor at the university and then he
got gunned down so you know steve kerr
one has a personal connection to it but
everything he was saying was so [ __ ]
valid about like enough man 50 senators
are holding the american public hostage
when 90 of americans regardless of
political affiliation want universal
background checks for guns but because
these [ __ ] politicians like
mitch mcconnell want to hold on to their
power these [ __ ] will not even
vote on the bill you know they just
[ __ ] leave it
yet
19 [ __ ] kids 19 more kids have
to die wait you don't have to go through
a background check before you get a gun
well i mean that's the thing it's like
places like buying a shotgun you could
just [ __ ] go to walmart and buy a
shotgun bro without a without a
background check no you could just
[ __ ] buy it
because i don't know anything about guns
right like i don't
it's not that i don't care to know it's
just that you know when you kind of grow
up in a lifestyle
where
you know you know a lot of people that
were killed you kind of get scared of
that
object in general right and i tend not
to be in places where
uh i know a lot of people hate to hear
this people who are very pro-gun they're
like well you don't know when things are
going to happen and you know you're you
are 100 right um but i'm not saying i
don't
own a gun per se but i don't know too
much about guns you know i don't know if
having to have you know get the license
or whatever and the background check is
stuff that's pertaining to california is
that well it's it does vary state by
state okay yeah obviously the laws yeah
some places are a little bit more lacks
about it some places are you know uh the
states that are very
uh let's say tend to be right-leaning
you know want to want to have more
liberal gun rights i think that's in
that in texas too like you can you can
give somebody a gun and they could
legally obtain it i don't know which
parts of texas but i heard that's true i
wouldn't be surprised yeah i wouldn't be
surprised and fact check that though
yeah and and look man it's
it's a tricky [ __ ] situation because
to say that um gun reform laws don't
work is complete [ __ ] [ __ ] look
at all the developed nations that exist
that have these gun violence
incidents these mass shootings right
here by far ahead of all of them right
why is that because guns are more
readily available here now i forget if
it was
australia or if it was uh in the uk but
after i i think it was a school shooting
incident that had happened back in the
day it was like australia new zealand i
forget yeah they voluntarily gave their
guns up yeah they said you know what
no
we don't owning a gun is not as
important as preventing something like
this from happening i mean the hard part
is is like
you know and i kind of sat and thought
about this and this also kind of
coincides with my trip to korea it's it
only reaffirmed my idea or the thought
and i wonder if people agree with this
that nobody has a singular identity of
what it means to be an american right
like we're not we're not really like a
homogenous country in terms of not just
political identity but just our identity
as what it is to be an american right
and the thing is for me in my personal
opinion i feel like
guns are the probably the one thing
that's
attached to your americanness you know
you take my [ __ ] gun you're gonna
take me to the grave too you know and so
when somebody says when somebody hears
the idea of gun reform what they hear is
like well you're trying to strip away my
american identity and the weird thing
about the american identity too and i'm
you know wrapping it back to the trip in
south korea is that
when you ask somebody who's korean mind
you this is a the country's a lot
smaller than america is right and also
the history is a lot deeper it's a lot
longer korea has an identity of what
korean people are when somebody says
right like
they have a certain pride that comes
along with it you know i was telling
edric the story when i was in korea
before you had to leave you have to take
a covet test before you get back into
the states it can't be an
over-the-counter one it has to
specifically be a pcr test so you can't
get it at a clinic you can't get at the
hospital you have to uh outdoor site you
have to get out of the clinic
went to the clinic and this lady was
asking us about our trip and
this was very poignant in terms of my
idea of what i believe a lot of korean
people feel is that she wanted to ask us
how our trip was because she wanted to
make sure that our identity or what we
thought of south korea was something of
a positive one so if we didn't have a
good meal or a good time she was gonna
buy us a meal before we left back to the
states
right and that kind of threw me off
because it wasn't that she was doing
something good out of it was the
goodness of her heart yeah but her
objective was these people need to know
how great our country is i want to leave
a positive impression on on what our
country and culture is about right
that's kind of the motive behind yeah
yeah
tourism in south korea from what i've
seen from a lot of people who are there
they enjoy it because it's money and
they want people to understand that
korea is a great place to be and korean
people are awesome yeah and that's kind
of like how the tourist tourism
mentality is over there uh from what i
felt that when i when i was having
conversations with these people right
and it wasn't just one person that
person there was like two or three other
people too so in total like maybe four
when you come to america i don't think
we have that same type of strength and
identity here yeah our identity is
different from my version of whatever
what it is to be american is vastly
different from the person down the block
and so on and so forth so when somebody
tries to take away this gun thing right
is the only thing that i say it's like
oh
this might be tied to the american
identity taking away my guns and the
reason why that bothers me is because
the way that people responded to this
situation for people who are hyper pro
gun owners is something i didn't really
appreciate because it wasn't
the first thing that came out their
mouth was i can't believe 19 kids die
they go well this is what happens when
you're not protected at all times you
better not take my guns yeah that took
precedence before having a conversation
about 19 children living their lives
exactly which bothers me yeah it doesn't
even piss me off it makes me sad it
makes me sad and it infuriates me yeah
because the fact is
where does that mindset stem from
entitlement [ __ ] entitlement right
this is my god-given [ __ ] right the
second amendment
my right to bear arms you are not gonna
take that away from me versus
where's the [ __ ] compassion
where is the sympathy where is the
thought of oh my [ __ ] god man
19 more children have died now
do i really need
my guns like this or am i as a
collective group right yeah be willing
to just forfeit it now
in
in the name of
keeping children safe keeping people
safe in the name of peace but that
thought never [ __ ] crosses the minds
of these
pro uh gun people it's always
well that's why you got to have a gun
yeah protect yourself
it's like that wouldn't happen around me
well okay so where are all these [ __ ]
good guys with guns to stop all of these
things from where are these
[ __ ] then why are why are all
of these mass shootings happening all
the time yet you got all these
[ __ ] are saying not on my watch
yeah yeah where were you for this then
where the [ __ ] were you
i think the hard part is is like
america is so
[ __ ] in terms of
gun ownership and gun laws in terms of
like like i said so attached to the
american identity
that in order for you to
take away these guns from people yeah
it's it's almost damn near impossible
now oh yeah for sure it's just like for
sure i people are too stupid it's like
oh this is a great solution but in order
for that to happen it goes back to my
staying of we need to have a homogeneous
idea of what it is to be an american and
people need to take pride in that so
when a country who's albeit a lot
smaller but they have a strong cultural
identity or a country identity they can
come together and say this is for the
better good of our country
whoa hold on before we continue my
friends a you guys heard of secret
society before that's s-c-r-t
s-o-c-i-e-t-y a contemporary fashion
basic line that started up by me and my
friends listen
i started up secret society with my
buddies because
um
fashion basics never die and you know in
a world full of industries and fashion
companies that try to sell you stuff
that's overpriced that you don't get
what your money is worth we wanted to
challenge those high-end brands by doing
what they do and doing it better but at
a better price better quality and it's
just the clothes are freaking dope if
you haven't copped your secret society
gear you don't know what you're missing
fashion basics are for everybody we
don't like to exclude anybody guy girl
whatever unisex we have it all
check our [ __ ] out it's amazing every
day that i'm on this podcast i'm rocking
something secret society not just
because i own a part of it but because i
truly enjoy the clothes and i wouldn't
be rocking something that i didn't love
and enjoy check out secret society
that's s-c-r-t-s-o-c-i-e-t-y
com and guess what our spring summer
launch is launching next week so caught
that gear we have vintage hues they look
so [ __ ] dope and let me tell you
something man when you get our [ __ ]
people going west hey but you get that
and you'll be like secret society
so secret society that's
s-c-r-t-s-o-c-i-e-t-y
dot com contemporary fashion basics for
everyone
there's been so many first of all like
the amount of illegal guns that are
circulating in this country
it's why it's
so impossible to take legal arms back
because there's so much [ __ ] illegal
weaponry here
yes well speaking of illegal guns i'll
say too like when i was younger the only
reason why i didn't get myself strapped
was because of
recognizing my anger issues when i was
younger and and
knowing what that might lead to if i
have a piece on me yeah yeah and even
though the idea behind having the peace
on me might be to like protect myself
one bad incident one bad situation might
lead to a loss of life even me losing my
life you know so i just avoided that all
together like you know what
i don't need to go down that path right
i don't need the gun to protect myself
like i'm gonna do without i wonder why
people
and i'm not sure if this is the actual
case
what the reason is behind
having universal background checks for
as being um
just mandated across all states it's not
left up to the state like everybody
should have a universal background check
because that's not even the idea of
taking a gun away is making sure that
these guns don't get into the wrong
hands exactly so i wonder what the
reason behind that is is it because
that's just loose legislation that
people fear that they won't be able to
get a gun at all because if you're if
you have a background check and most
like everything in this country is these
background checks even for when you get
a driver's license are so [ __ ] loose
yeah it would be nice if there was a
standard for it though like somewhat
that's but it's not that hard to [ __ ]
get a gun in america it's really not
that hard and that's why these things
happen time and time again and every
time like you just said every time it
happens you got a bunch of people coming
making sure hey that's why i got my gun
because this [ __ ] isn't going to happen
on my watch not you know if anybody
tries to come around and you know harm
me or my family i got my gun to protect
myself you know
versus compassion right that's that's
what's so [ __ ] man about about being
in america and like you said earlier i
love this country i was born here and
and like the freedoms that i have the
rights that i have here i appreciate it
but a lot of the times man i feel very
disheartened as well when i see all the
[ __ ] that's going on in this country and
a lot of people's reactions to it and
there's nothing there's no like
progressive thoughts on how to make it
better it's
not [ __ ] that i'm gonna hold on to what
i think is right there there's no open
mind in this you know and and like going
back to the whole story that you were
sharing about the doctor uh making sure
like that that person or a couple had a
had a meal to leave a good impression
that's because they're what we talked
about earlier their pride in their
culture wants them to leave a positive
impression of it right yeah the pride
here and of being an american is of
entitlement and almost elitism like
we're better than you yeah our country
is number one america i mean come on we
know that right america number one right
yeah always the best at everything and
anything i think that kind of goes into
my idea of what i either was expecting
or wasn't expecting when i traveled to
south korea right because we're kind of
you know force-fed this thought this
idea that listen america is the best at
everything we are we ha we are the
[ __ ] [ __ ] but then when i went into
south korea it's not that i was
expecting south korea to be trash i just
didn't realize how dope it was to that
extent
what are we the best at though let's be
honest are we the best we're good at
student loans yes we're the best at
mass shootings mass shootings
we're the best at um highest cost of
education yes uh we're the best at uh
most debt yes
those are the things we're number one at
what what are the things that actually
[ __ ] matter where we rank at in terms
of happiness
yeah there you go military that's what
it's always all what it's all about and
and it's it goes kind of hand in hand
with a gun thing right
but yeah happiness level uh the amount
of vacation people have in a year we
rank the [ __ ] bottom on all that [ __ ]
you know and it's like so what really
makes america number one the fact that
if you try to [ __ ] with us we will blow
you to [ __ ] smithereens off the face
of the planet that's where a lot of our
money goes into right yeah why it's like
it's very difficult
which is kind of which i i mean
there's definitely people who are in the
military or somebody who knows more
about this that could probably explain
you know where this funding goes and why
it's important well
i mean look man when we see things like
uh the situation in ukraine with russia
invading them right
we look at it and it's like well
that's wrong on every single level right
and then you look at
place like america dude our hands aren't
clean we got [ __ ] blood on our hands
too there was a gaff made by george w
recently who was actually condemning the
whole russian invasion of ukraine but he
misspoke and he said iraq the situ so he
said all this [ __ ] and then and then he
goes well i mean it's true
so he publicly admitted that the war on
iraq was a fabricated war and it was
completely wrong to do
and it's like well
yeah yeah too late bro yeah i mean
that's what everybody had said but you
just [ __ ] confirmed it now you know i
mean that's the hard part too like
because three three pretty crazy mass
shootings within two weeks is nuts man
it is there was the one that happened
pretty close to us in the oc where it
was a the taiwanese church taiwanese
church out in the oc yeah and there was
a story about a doctor there who tried
to step in and save people and he got
[ __ ] killed because he tried to be a
hero yeah and so and i heard too when i
was reading certain things too they go
see if he had a gun he could have
stopped them but he didn't
which yeah i get but
if we had no guns it wouldn't have
happened period right let's let's not
skip that part let's not go to the part
where well if if i if he had a gun they
wouldn't have if the [ __ ] crazy
ass didn't have a gun though it wouldn't
have happened period were they saying
that this was uh race motivated it
wasn't race related it was uh
i don't know if you call it race so it
was a chinese guy who
was anti-taiwanese
oh he was a chinese guy
get the [ __ ] out of here yeah yeah so it
was anti-he
was very pro-china and very anti-taiwan
and but okay that doesn't even [ __ ]
make sense yeah you know why because
you could what is the purpose of china
being anti-taiwan
what is that what is the big
purpose does that serve because right
now and which is a sensitive topic is
what taiwan wants doesn't want to be a
part of china right china doesn't want
to be or taiwan doesn't want to be a
part of um china they want to be their
own independent country so to speak and
biden um
kind of backed it up saying yeah
we're gonna militarily he would he it's
the first time he said explicitly that
he would uh back them up militarily like
he would act militarily and then he
backtracked a little bit but yeah it's
under china's one china policy yeah
where it says this is all a part of
china but taiwan is saying
nah bro
we've been kind of doing our own thing
for a while
but then some of these very pro-china
people um are like nah you guys belong
to us which that's what i'm saying it
just doesn't make sense for you to go
ahead and kill people who are part of
your countrymen
if it's if the objective is you're
taiwan you're not taiwanese you're
actually chinese the objective to go in
and murder people who are your kindred
countrymen doesn't make any sense i
think it's counter to it i think i think
in their mind they're trying to wipe out
the people who
have that pro-taiwan stance and go to
taiwan [ __ ] yeah
because because there are people in
taiwan who who are um from china yeah
who who don't uh have any qualms about
saying yeah we're a part of china but
then you have the i i forgot if it's
like the green party or some [ __ ] i i
forget what the colors are who are very
pro taiwan and it's like nah we're we're
our own thing we're our own entity you
guys we're separate from you guys you
know
it should like i mean i know
people from taiwan who look down on
mainlanders like oh i know a lot of
people
like don't you ever [ __ ] call me
chinese you know that's the thing too i
i had a friend she said she was uh
taiwanese yeah and i didn't know what
taiwanese was yeah me too i don't know i
didn't either so i kind of
you know i didn't understand how deep
that emotion and feeling was yeah
because in my mind i read the history
yeah right very loosely and i don't
remember now but all i know is that
there is an indigenous people of taiwan
right and
they were basically pushed out to the to
the fringes yeah and
people in china took over and these
indigenous taiwanese people they're
taiwanese yeah and so when she says i'm
taiwanese i'm like no you're chinese and
she took like offense to that this is a
girl i was dating by the way
and she was like no i'm not chinese i
was like what do you mean you're not
chinese like you're
you're not an indigenous taiwanese
person like i was explaining to her in
my eyes because i don't know i didn't
know about the history and how they felt
about it was
that's like saying like
you're telling me right now that you're
native american just because you're a
white person that came on a boat and you
settled here and said you're a native
american person that's what it sounds
like to me or but she was trying to
explain to me she goes no i'm from
taiwan i'm taiwanese i'm like no you're
chinese
the taiwanese people are there they're
indigenous they're they're they're
taiwanese people and i didn't really
understand like the social political
implications of the things that i was
saying yeah right which i get it i
understand but um yeah i wish i i could
redo that
yeah dude some people take like great
offense to if they're taiwanese and you
call them chinese don't you [ __ ] care
yeah don't choose you call me a dirty
chinese i am taiwanese so they
so that guy was trying to kill them
because of his pro-china sound yes
because of let me let me let me see this
guy's name let me see um
uh the doctor by the way was i believe
john chang was his name shout outs to
john chang man wrestling
yeah
um so
i
was a u.s citizen who actually grew up
in taiwan but he was motivated by his
hatred of the self-governing
himself i guess
and he hated oh his family was
reportedly among those forcibly removed
from mainland china to taiwan okay so he
was they were forcibly removed and so he
i guess had that very strong feeling
that sense of identity of being chinese
and he's like [ __ ] these
people i'm gonna murder them but that's
he's a crazy he's a crazy guy he's i
mean he's a crazy person clearly a lot
of the times i mean no not a lot of the
times i would say [ __ ] hundred
percent of the time it's a crazy person
yeah it's a crazy person the idea that
somebody who's that mentally unstable
can get their hands on like
semi-automatic weapons is [ __ ] nuts
to me yeah it's it's kind of crazy and
even before that you said there was this
is this is one i know nothing buffalo
new york there was something that
happened in buffalo new york which that
was supposed to be a racially
facially motivated incident it was a
white kid um again who will remain
nameless [ __ ] this kid um he
basically had
this long-standing like pro-white stance
right and he was buying into the idea of
i forget what the actual term is called
but it's like this idea that the white
race is is dying out and they've got to
make sure that this doesn't happen for
real bro
no there's there's an actual term for it
i forgot what it was called um but it's
the idea behind it is that the white
race is dying out
if that would make sense
um so
he
targeted this area based on um
kind of the demographics the population
of black people yeah and he knew that
there would be black people there is it
true i'm not this could just be me
reading things and me not kind of
looking into it carefully that he wrote
edward with the hard r on his rifle that
it was really that i don't know that i'm
not sure
brighton farts this podcast is brought
to you by raycon my friends keep this
podcast going by supporting our sponsors
and raycon has been sponsoring us for
quite a while because i love them just
came back from south korea guess what i
use on the plane to watch my anime
that's right your boy is an anime
fanatic i watched jiu jitsu kaizen with
my raikon earbuds and guess what amazing
they were so light and comfortable
forgot they were in my ear and i just
fell asleep right on the plane
that's awesome raycon's everyday earbuds
look feel and sound better than ever
with optimized gel tips for the perfect
in-ear fit these earbuds are so
comfortable and no they will not budge
trust
me i love my [ __ ] biking boxing whatever
you call it they're in my ear ready to
go every day check out raycon's wireless
earbuds my guess is that you're going to
want to leave them a five star review
too go to buy raycon dot com slash brain
today to get 15 off your recon order
that's by raycon dot com slash brain
score 15 off by raycon dot com slash
brain
um i know he had like a whole
thing that he wrote um and he had a
manifesto yeah he did have a manifest
well i don't know if they were calling
it a manifesto but it might have been
just like his journals like his diaries
or
just writings that he had written about
his thoughts and ideas
i think so
[Laughter]
i don't know if it was a journal or a
manifesto but yeah he clearly had these
ideas and thoughts that were very
i want to read this diary though yeah um
and and i think he also was a poster on
like 4chan too or or he adopted ideas
from of course june 16th yeah i saw
another black person my day was ruined
like what the [ __ ] this guy's a [ __ ]
loser dude i add another one that i'm
gonna kill to the list um but no the
what was especially
disturbing about this one was he live
streamed this [ __ ] on twitch
oh
yeah he live streamed this [ __ ] bro i
mean the feed got cut off i think about
two and a half minutes into it because
people recognize
what was happening yeah this
bro i saw i saw the video i can't watch
this it's
it's [ __ ] brutal dude it's he so he
starts recording from him in the car
driving up to the market so he's on the
road pulls into the market
parks right in front of the entrance
i don't even think he turns off his
engine he puts it in park literally as
soon as he gets out he starts firing
first person he sees i think he murders
him murders them i think he shoots him
like twice
um but
yeah this was uh
racially motivated and and he was
targeting black people uh specifically
that's why he went to the neighborhood
that he went to and went to the market
that he went to because he knew it was a
market that um predominantly had uh
african-american customers so
another one of those incidents do you
know how many people have passed away um
double digit double digits jam it's up
there yeah i think it was like 11.
let me let me let me double check you
know what the crazy thing about this is
too it's just um
you know we we we do have a lot of these
conversations in this country where i do
agree racism obviously isn't as bad as
it was 30 years ago yeah but there's
still a handful of people out there that
denies that racism exists in this
country
and
i i don't understand what the the stance
is on that you can
recognize that racism isn't as bad as as
it was 30 40 years ago but you can also
recognize that racism is still prevalent
and still i would i would argue
racism is more or less the same it's
just that the laws have changed right to
favor equal rights you know right yeah
so yeah we can probably all agree that
obviously like during the times of you
know people's grandparents and
then it's substantially better now yeah
you know in terms of laws and stuff but
racial sentiments still are around and
you see it in cases like this i mean and
once again it goes back to just
i wonder where the empathy is for people
right where they see this and they go
well that was just a crazy person it
doesn't mean anything why is that the
first thing out of your [ __ ] mouth
yeah i don't understand it like i want
to understand people's objective what is
your objective is your objective to say
that to be like ha i told you so uh or
is your objective just to say well by
the way i want to be right about
something and you know i'm sick and
tired of white people getting pushed
around which i don't know what where the
[ __ ] you're getting that from but i i do
see that it's like i should i always
feel guilty i don't think that's the
case right
um
i think when we have a conversation
about racism with people who are white
americans i do understand where
sometimes they feel like
okay how long do i have to apologize for
i think that's a very bad take on it
it's not a sense of you have to
apologize for what your ancestors did
it's when you want to tell somebody that
it's not a big deal because it's not you
in their shoes right you go well that
was like i don't know 60 years ago why
are you [ __ ] on me for this it's not
that it's just you have an attitude of
denying that this has had a ripple
effect of repercussions to these people
who are right before you right now
those type of stuff transfers over
there's generational trauma that happens
a lot absolutely and i'm pretty sure
that they've had their own personal
generational trauma whether they came i
don't know from europe from a poor
country or whatever and if you can
recognize that you can understand how
slavery or even not just slavery like
systemic racism which was put into law
here where we had to have separate
bathrooms where they couldn't eat in the
same dining there's people who are alive
till this day that still experience
experience that it hasn't been that long
it hasn't so it's not about you feeling
personal guilt for it i think it's more
of an issue of you denying that
people have experienced this or that or
that there's no inequality even like
what are you talking about it's it's the
same for me as it is for you no it's
[ __ ] not man
no it's not it's never been it probably
never will be it's sad to say that but
that that's the [ __ ] reality you have
a mutual friend too where she was
telling us about her husband who was you
know who at the time
kind of underst like
you know as a black man was like okay i
understand what's going on in this
country with my people but you know
maybe some of these situations aren't as
bad as people say it well he had a
personal experience too where i mean she
could come on the podcast and tell the
story because it's [ __ ] nuts and i
might be butchering it right now but
he essentially was on a train and this
is a guy who is a professional he's like
in a suit and everything else like that
gets into an altercation with the cop
because he uh fell asleep on the train
and they tased him and they beat the
[ __ ] out of him oh my god
are you serious i'm talking about
because he fell asleep he had his uh
work
tag oh my god on him like his work tag
on him and he has like a briefcase and a
suit in the whole shebang and he fell
asleep on and they were treating him
like he was a like some crackhead or a
junkie which even then if he was you
still shouldn't be treating people like
that but they and she was on the phone
with him as he was being like
interrogated and they tasted his ass
what can you do but [ __ ] laugh
because it's so ridiculous it's it's
it's [ __ ] so ridiculous that it's
like comical you know but i mean [ __ ]
man add that to
the you know infinite list of other
incidents like that that happen across
this country on a daily basis that we
just don't hear about or know about but
we can say with certain level of
certainty that it is happening you know
by the way the buffalo count it said 10
10 were killed and three were wounded
um but did you imagine
like you just walk out and you're going
i don't know what store he shot up yeah
it's it's it's a local chain i had never
heard of it before a grocery store or
something yeah no that's seriously
exactly what it like a woman is just
walking and then she just gets shot
killed
someone shopping in the store shot and
killed and then people start to realize
oh [ __ ] something's going on people
start scrambling running away panicking
but
yeah dude like can you imagine just
[ __ ] looking oh you know what kind of
cereal should i boom dead that's it
you're [ __ ] dead or even worse you
see a [ __ ] loved one get killed to
death like that what if you survived a
shot you know i mean
yeah it's just
yeah and i i know i
i wonder too if it comes with age when
people start to realize like the gravity
of the situation you know there's a lot
of people in this country or just people
in general who are who are blessed with
very peaceful and calm lives and they
never had to be faced with a situation
where you lost somebody through death
you know or somebody to be taken away
very abruptly in their life so it's it's
like
how do you explain to people the tragedy
and i think what happens to is a lot of
us have become so desensitized because
of this [ __ ] happening so frequently
that when they hear these stories it
doesn't really rock them yeah because
think about it like this this stuff is
all over the news quote unquote right um
but
sandy hook which was [ __ ] nuts
and their numbers aren't that far off
from this one yeah this is the worst one
since san diego
yeah and i
take is still tick talking like it
normally is instagram is still going
like it normally is
and it's so sad because now i understand
it's like oh because this subject
doesn't give you social currency and
credit and because not your your
favorite celebrities aren't talking
about it right now because there aren't
people protesting out in the middle of
the streets yeah there's no crazy crazy
amount of social media coverage you just
don't care yeah but if there was you
would feel an urge to make a post about
this but i checked all of instagram
today
maybe two people talked about it yeah
how [ __ ] crazy and this is one of the
biggest mass massacres specifically of
children since the sandy hook incident
and the sandy hook incident by the way
has
documentaries about it because of how
[ __ ] insane exactly man and look you
don't have to have gone through anything
remotely close to feel a sense of like
compassion and and disgust and anger
from seeing this hat like come on man
imagine your [ __ ] little brother
little sister your cousin your nephew
your niece was one of these kids who
were just [ __ ] sitting in class at
school and then this crazy [ __ ]
comes in there and shoots him in the
head and kills him you know like just
imagine that you know what i mean you
don't have to have experienced violence
ever in your life to recognize how
[ __ ] foul and terrible of an incident
this is true but once again i i feel
like a lot of young people aren't even
connected to people they don't care
because they're
you just said it man this [ __ ] social
currency this [ __ ] ain't gonna give me
likes this [ __ ] ain't gonna give me
[ __ ] clout like oh let me let me hop
on this next dance trend matter of fact
let me try let me hop on this tic tac
tic top dance challenge
it's so [ __ ] sad man and look i'm a
[ __ ] nobody on social media i don't
have a platform but like that's why i
try to make an active effort to share
like these big news because if even one
person looks at that and maybe they
weren't aware of it and they think oh my
god this is [ __ ] because it's all
about awareness right it starts with
awareness
and so
yeah it does deeply [ __ ] disturb me
when you when when i see what you
mentioned like things like this happen
and it's just like nothing happened yeah
when when if you're on these social
media platforms you would have no
[ __ ] clue that something like this
even happened well the crazy thing is
too like i i look at social media you
know my idea and view of social media
changes constantly now yeah and now i'm
starting to see this
i'm really starting to believe that
social media like stuff like quick
content like tick tock is honestly
becoming like the downfall of human
society
and i know it sounds like i'm being
very hyperbolic like i'm exaggerating
this [ __ ] but i want you guys to
understand just just this and i'm not
again a social media created this
lifestyle that i have now
right but i feel like because i'm in an
earlier generation i balance it out a
lot better than most people do yeah
right but now it's very odd how your
value is tied to this thing
everything your life your self-worth
whatever the [ __ ] that it is and the
dumber and more outlandish things that
you do is constantly rewarded you get
this endorphin
of like yo okay so i did this fake video
where i pretended to be mad at my
girlfriend and i or i faked these social
justice stuff and i get more views i get
more likes and now this is becoming a
standard of what a high society person
is it's like oh the most valued people
aren't based on their skill and their
intellect anymore it's based on how
outlandish they are so our value of an
elite human being has nothing to do with
skill or intelligence now yeah has
everything to do with what you did to
make sure that you are the most known
the idea of a celebrity too isn't based
on skill yeah it's not it's not at all
it's some of these people like what are
you what what do you what is it that you
do what are you famous for like what is
an influencer oh i
i pose yeah
well
i post yeah
you know come again
excuse me what do you mean can you
elaborate but this is ex this is what
i'm talking about yeah are
our level of revelry for these people of
high skills are people without skills
and they are the people at the top of
society now yeah it's
maybe not the top of society but in in
your general community they're they're
in an elite circle of of like influence
and now these people are what the young
people are trying to imitate when you
ask people like in these elementary
schools um like teachers you'll see what
a majority of what these kids say they
go what do you want to be when you grow
up yeah they say youtube or tick-tock
yeah streamer
yeah not
cop not
um a doctor not a lawyer not a business
owner somebody who owns a restaurant
somebody who cooks food nothing that has
to do with actual skill they're
essentially when they say youtuber is
not i want to do this because of this
job i do this because i want people to
love me yeah that's that's the [ __ ] the
part about it is that
dude
you already know what it is my friends
this podcast is brought to you by better
help so many of you guys have dm me
messaged me that you've never tried
therapy before but you tried better help
and now it's an everyday part of your
routine sometimes every day sometimes
bi-weekly sometimes
try monthly however you like it better
help has your back life can be
overwhelming and many people are burned
out without even knowing it symptoms can
include lack of motivation feeling
helpless or trapped detachment fatigue
and more my friends your mental health
is important and everybody who has tried
better health through this podcast guess
what i am proud of you i'm happy that
you're getting rid of that that negative
stigma that therapy has in your head and
you're trying this for yourself and
you're getting better because my friends
i'm right there with you been using
better help for quite a while now and i
ain't gonn stop ever better help is
customize online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with your therapist so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to it's much more affordable than in
person therapy and you can be messed
with the therapist in under 48 hours
genius brainlisters get 10 off their
first month at betterhelp.com genius
that's betterhelp.com
genius
technolo this type of technology was a
blessing in a sense that you like some
of these talented independent creators
who might you know for whatever reason
might have not got any recognition or
attention maybe they're just in a bum
[ __ ] nowhere in somewhere in the world
right and they don't have that type of
platform but now all of a sudden they
have this platform to be able to share
their skills and their talent and people
can see it and recognize it but then
that started to slowly morph into okay
what is gonna get the most amount of
tension in the shortest amount of time
now it's okay how can we get the most
amount of likes and views within 11
seconds or less yeah that's the motive
now that's the goal and so
what can you really do and say in 11
seconds right
not much yeah but now there's like a
formula people figure out to like
squeeze these things some of the worst
videos and if you're a content creator
that watches this and this is what you
do you're a [ __ ] loser
i'm sorry
whatever you're going to say i already
agree i don't even know what it is that
you're going to say but i agree a video
and they put a video of them in the
corner explaining what we're already
watching
how do you live with yourself
how they go oh my god they're lighting
that candle on fire oh my god it's
melting
well wax melts that fast
whoa this is crazy oh my god there's
another candle within that candle guys i
never expected
but that's become a trend though you
know but the sad thing about that is
yeah there's like a couple of videos
that do well and then the other ones get
no views but they still do that because
they're still chasing that one video
that blew up i know you are a [ __ ]
loser
you you offer nothing in terms of skill
yeah what you do literally anybody can
do yeah you know and i know they say
that a lot about stuff that i do but you
literally can't do it number number
three
you're a [ __ ] loser
[Laughter]
first you're a loser two you can't do
anything three you're a [ __ ] loser
and he's like literally if i had a
conversation with this person like what
do you do for a living i uh
i i talk about i i don't you don't i
don't even talk about videos i describe
what you're already watching
i narrate i mean you know what their
answer to that is is like
amen they're hustling
are they
in what sense you ain't no [ __ ]
david attenborough bro yeah you ain't
got that voice if you were david
attenborough right and you're like
you're the candidate
the sea urchin crawls across the seabed
in order to look for its prey
yeah
i might give you some [ __ ] respect
but you describing candle wax melting
yeah i don't need it
nobody [ __ ] needs i don't need a
[ __ ]
narration the idea behind that too the
majority of the comments is people
calling him a [ __ ] loser yeah that i
mean that's that's what's sad man in in
today's society i don't get it we don't
we don't get it but you know that's
again that's what's sad is it doesn't
make sense but because people are so
[ __ ] um
i guess
obsessed with getting likes and with
getting views they're willing to do
anything try anything
even if it's like
something that may come off as cringe or
embarrassing in some cases they even
[ __ ] purposely try to be cringe or
embarrassing right
it's just so that again they can get
those likes they can get those views but
it's like man to the young people i just
want to say to them like i really would
hope you guys can maybe take a week or
two just take a little break from social
media from online [ __ ] and see what it
does for your life
no longevity in that [ __ ] either and
look man to each their own [ __ ] if they
enjoy doing that and they get some sort
of [ __ ] fulfillment or satisfaction
happiness from it then by all means but
when i look at that i'm just like come
on man there's a little more to life
than that yeah and i'm not saying i
dislike tik tok or fast content i think
it's entertaining it's dope there's a
purp there's a place for it yeah and i'm
talking about the mentality and psyche
that a lot of people have going into it
thinking that it's going to be their
be-all end-all and they found out that
their success only lasts for less than a
year and they keep searching for this
next big hit yeah and they keep
searching for this over and over and
over again they wonder why they're not
valued as a person that's when this [ __ ]
becomes [ __ ] up and that's where a lot
of [ __ ] young people are going
through right now like you have to
understand something you're basing
um value into something that's super
fleeting dude nobody gives a [ __ ] about
you at the end of the day when you die
and you're waking up miserable every day
because you're chasing [ __ ] this idea
of love and affection for people who
don't give a [ __ ] about you you're gonna
end up sad as [ __ ] i've seen it with
so many youtubers yeah and youtube
wasn't even as bad as tic toc is now
yeah and i've seen these guys collapse
i've seen them [ __ ] go into they had
to go into extensive therapy they had to
disappear for years and come back and
learn that this stuff doesn't [ __ ]
matter of course man of course and look
it's
there's no
legacy with it
or i'm not gonna say there's no legacy
but the chances of you leaving behind
the legacy are pretty slim because
there's so much [ __ ] content and
content creators now
you might pop off for one week but
you're hot for that day in the week
that's it
and you're forgotten completely you had
that one and done that's why people it's
hard to explain like i put out this
tweet the other day was just a joke but
it's but there's a realness to it um
people wonder why i never kept my
youtube play buttons i had a gold one
and a silver one and i didn't that's
right i actually me being friends with
you all this time i've never
realized yeah
it was annoying to keep around when i
was moving it's gigantic it's huge
you're like [ __ ] this [ __ ] i threw it
away yeah i don't need it yeah like
it's not me trying to say like oh i'm
better than this it's just it doesn't i
don't i genuinely just don't care for it
right i remember too like the moment i
hit half a million uh followers i was
like oh i can do this yeah and that
number didn't matter to me anymore yeah
yeah because if you notice on my channel
i never really follow trends like
whatever trend was hot at the time you
never saw it on my channel right and the
reason why wasn't because i was trying
to be different i just wasn't genuinely
interested in it yeah and so if if i
wasn't interested in doing something
like this which is completely left up to
my choice then i might as well just work
on nine to five because if it's just for
a paycheck there's other jobs that make
a lot more money than this or a
substantial amount of money yeah that's
a lot more stable yeah and i would have
done that instead yeah and look me as
your friend you know we've been friends
for how long now like eight years
something like that um
me just kind of like getting an inside
look at how you worked and what your
creative process was like it's something
that you know i've and i told you this
before too that i respected and admired
because at the time like your generation
of content creators on youtube what they
were doing right a lot of them
i was like you know
this [ __ ] is pretty whack and and from a
standpoint of like you could clearly
tell they don't have like that creative
inclination yeah and and not only that
their work ethic is just not there it
shows in the quality of the work but
then for you like how much you cared
about the content and like the
creativity behind it and then yeah it
it's a testament though
because look at where you are now in
terms of staying relevant through all
those years look at all the content
creators that you came up with how many
of them are relevant today not a lot
exactly yeah exactly so that's a
testament to like you staying in your
lane and doing what you feel like brings
you some sort of fulfillment scratches
that creative itch and yeah makes you
feel like this is not a nine-to-five
yeah and the the i think the biggest
thing that i focused on too was i
stopped worrying about new followers i
only i started caring about the people
who stuck with me your community your
community and that community to me
matters more than the people that who
are going to come in later not to say
that new followers don't matter yeah but
i can't keep catering to a new audience
that aren't going to stick around
never-ending [ __ ] thing yeah there's
people that i've met that followed me
for 10 years yeah and they still follow
me till this day they still wait for
these videos they're waiting for vlogs
to happen even though most likely it's
not gonna happen again
you know
but you know it's very much appreciated
right and that type of effort matters
you know and to tie it back to just kind
of what we were talking about before i
just
yeah you might think it's it's an
exaggeration where i say it's like the
downfall of the site but i don't see us
rebounding back from this i don't see us
rebounding back from a society where
people are just glued to their phones 24
7. and i fall into that category too
where i see myself on my phone a little
bit too often right albeit my living is
based off of it
but there's a reason why i haven't
really made such efforts to be a part of
the whole entertainment machine yeah i
like where i'm at right now i like doing
what i'm doing the moment i step over to
that other side i'm at the the the will
and call of this entertainment machine
sucking ass kissing ass uh [ __ ]
schmoozing with people sucking dick
licking clits
not only are you kissing ass you're
sucking out
i'm sucking ass that's the new one i'm
trying to get
i'm trying to suck their heart to their
[ __ ]
this is what i'm doing now you know and
i just i had a taste of it and it it
sucks i i dislike it very much and
people are
understandably turned off by me because
i don't play the game you know they go
oh hey man and like i do i did this at
the last little mixer event that i was
at yeah person comes out to me won't say
their name and they go do men i love
your [ __ ] i you know i watch your stuff
all the time i was like what was my last
video
they started stuttering and i saw sweat
coming off their face i was like i'm
just giving you [ __ ] bro yeah i was like
you don't got to say yeah don't say that
if you don't [ __ ] mean it just say
what's up
you don't got to like all my [ __ ] yeah
you don't have to do all that [ __ ] bro
it's like leave that hollywood [ __ ] at
the door like just say you used to watch
my [ __ ] yeah and you liked what i did or
just say what's up
you know what i mean just introduce
yourself as a person yeah yeah my bad
man you know she's hollywood [ __ ] i just
you know i kind of say that [ __ ] real
fast it's like i get it but you know i'm
not really hollywood so you don't need
to do all that stuff like that when you
showed them your ass sugar and last suck
it yeah i was like listen
now it's time for me to suck your ass
spread it open and i suck
all the way through and he had corn that
day
i could tell
[Music]
well guys that wraps up this episode of
the genius brain podcast uh if you have
any suggestions or thoughts about like
gun control and this is obvious
something that i don't really know too
much about yeah let's let's preface it
too is we're not we're not saying we're
authorities on this topic or that we're
you know we know everything all the ins
and outs we're expressing our opinions
and our outlook on it and in like in
light of these recent incidents which i
think universally people should be able
to agree on is [ __ ] heinous is
terrible it shouldn't happen and what
can we do to make sure it doesn't happen
all i know is that apparently if you
write journals and diaries like a little
[ __ ] loser apparently the next step
is to shoot up a school
yeah that's your legacy dude
the [ __ ] diary writing [ __ ]
yeah you could check uh edric out at ed2
on instagram and also secret society uh
this is coming out this week so probably
the week after we're gonna be launching
our spring summer lunch it was supposed
to be right
i wonder if that reads if it probably
not yeah but anyway this is like a vinyl
heat transfer that's on here it might
look matte gray uh for those of you
might be watching but based on the light
the intensity and how the angle it hits
it you see a spectrum of different
colors which is super [ __ ] dope yeah
yeah yeah well guys catch jesus brain
every sundays at 12 p.m secret society
that's s-c-r-t-s-o-c-i-e-t-y
dot com look for that new drop if not we
have our back to basics collection which
is should be filling up your closets
either way because you can match
anything and everything with this the
hat by the way is from the back to basis
collection it goes with the vintage hues
it goes with everything yeah it's all
mix and match oh mix and match we'll see
you all next time peace